what's up alienation today I'm going to
share with you my seven strategies to
help you dominate social media in 2017
so I recently got asked to do an
interview about my thoughts on where
social media was going in 2017 because I
was featured in Forbes magazine as one
of their top 40 social marketing talents
and so I shared my thoughts and then
thought to myself I should share with
you guys so you can dominate your social
media in 2017 - so here are my seven
ways number one is small business will
keep brands from all the brands that
I've seen they really suck at social the
content sucks there's there's a lot of
production quality in it it looks
fantastic but they miss the authenticity
and they miss the storytelling and they
miss the heart and this is your chance
guys everybody's on social it's such an
amazing way to drive traffic to drive
attention to drive customers to your
business it'll increasingly in 2017 be
one of the primary drivers for any
entrepreneur in your company and it's
your chance to stand out for
entrepreneurs this has always been like
your story your authenticity has always
been the way to stand out if you have a
website that looks super corporate and
boring because you're trying to compete
with the big guys you're always going to
lose because if you look the same as one
of the big guys the only reason I'm
going to go with you is because of price
and that's not the game you want to be
in you should be able to charge a
premium for what you do because I can
connect with you on a personal level I
love your story I love your passion I
love your commitment I feel like I'm
gonna get better service with someone
who actually cares then going to the big
company and because authenticity and
storytelling is how small companies win
now you have the platform people go out
and win at a bigger scale now it's not
just relying on people to visit your
website or meet you at a trade show you
can do it through content to youtube
videos through your twitter through
snapchat through Instagram all these
different plot
give you the ability like never before
to reach an audience with your authentic
story and passion in a way that brands
can't the brand's are boring use that to
your advantage to win and eat them
[Music]
number two as video is going to dominate
video is going to become more and more
and more and more important and it's not
just YouTube
we have snapchat we have Instagram
storage we have Twitter get into video
everybody's getting into video the four
of us every different different lengths
doesn't matter but video is going to be
more and more more and more and more
important everybody has a device now
similarly record video and high quality
video and so being able to practice your
storytelling in front of a camera to
share your expertise to show off why you
love doing what you're doing so much to
be positioned as the expert in your
industry is going to become so much more
important and I really encourage you
guys to start practicing your video
storytelling again this is an easy way
to stand out because you you interview
somebody at a big brand at a corporation
their videos are they're so bad there's
no connection they don't know what it's
like actually dealing with a customer
where you do you feel the customers
every single day where some manager at
some big company doesn't and so video is
an amazing opportunity to stand out the
people who are going to win are either
the one to have great storytelling right
can be authentic and answer questions
can can connect their passion through
the camera and also the ones who might
be more gearheads
who can focus on the 360 video who can
focus on the 4k and 8k right have
something different you don't need to be
at the high end you this is enough your
phone is enough if you're passionate and
you're an expert sharing that content is
enough to make me feel that connection
to you and make me want to buy from you
the other thing in video we're going to
see more of his life everybody's pushing
live people want to see behind the
scenes which is a big advantage for
entrepreneurs because when it's live
people don't expect the production
quality if somebody's just snapping some
videos they're doing facebook live
expected to be from a phone you don't
need to have a camera
you don't need to have the light setup
an expensive gear and five people around
you holding different microphones you
need any of that the costs have come
down to zero the cops have come down to
this right you have it you have the same
ability as every big brand to win in
live video it's only going to be more
and more and more and more and more and
more and more and more and more
important so start doing it ASAP number
of Korea's mobile first will win you
have to be paying attention to mobile
look at your website look at where
people are coming from look at the past
five years no matter what industry
you're going to be in you'll see that
mobile is taking up a greater greater
greater greater chunk of your visitors
and in the next 12 to 24 months it may
be almost all of your business and so it
depends on the industry for some
companies already the number one traffic
source for some it's 30 percent or 40
percent what it's getting there and so
if you're thinking about your next
website or your next social media you
know post you're going to be putting up
you have to be thinking mobile first I'm
in a process that we do my websites for
both businesses you should be looking at
yours don't just assume that people
going to be using a desktop forever and
optimized around that or a laptop it has
to be mobile the companies that are
going mobile first are going to win it's
only going to get more important start
now don't lose out don't be here in in
18 months and wondering why your
business tanked where when I go to your
website on on a mobile phone it looks
like crap and I can't find your
information right you need to fill in
for mobile first number four is
advertising costs are going to rise
they'll keep rising it's still actually
a great deal if you look at Facebook ads
if you want to target Facebook ads is
still an amazing deal compared to any
other platform but the bigger brains are
starting to pay attention the big brains
are always behind it's just the nature
the briefs they're still spending money
on TV and radio and billboard there's
still spending money but it's shifting
it's now shifting they realize how far
behind they are and it's starting to
shift and so the opportunity window is
closing down advertising costs are going
to go up as
big brands start shifting their budget
from TV into online but there's still an
opportunity now there's still a window
within the next 12 to 24 months to
really capitalize and I've been looking
to Facebook first if you can specify a
target audience you know that these are
the people that you need to target you
know we do it for eternity itself we
look at people who are between 25 years
old and 35 years old is our sweet spot
and we run targeted campaigns against
them then like this will look like this
within a geographic area so whatever
your business is if you can target if
you know what your target audience looks
like I would still be on Facebook Ads as
a number-one advertising platform for
you but costs are going to go up so you
have to be smarter but how you do it
[Music]
number five is influencer marketing is
going to explode it's going to happen
you have to realize that the people with
the voice now the people with the
audience is not just the big network
it's not just put an ad on some TV show
and hoping that things are going to take
off especially YouTube and Instagram
people with large followings and
building up snapchat now - people with
large followings getting them to endorse
or use your product it's not just about
hoping that Kim Kardashian where is your
shoes and you take off you can get
insane results from other influencers
and those prices are going to rise as
well right now it's massively
underpriced to work with influencers to
get their buy-in because there's not as
much demand if you think about
advertising costs coming up the next
wave is going to be influencer marketing
and so that's an opportunity while the
big brands are slow and sluggish and
behind it's an opportunity for
entrepreneurs to identify who are the 10
influencers that my audience cares about
and how do I get them to work with my
business talk about my product or
service be a user while the costs are
still really cheap the other thing to
think about for influencer marketing is
you have to let them control the message
this is something I think entrepreneurs
are better at than big brand a lot of
brands that you have to do this you have
to mention these five points about how
great our product is you need to
understand you do with creative people
they know their audience better than you
do they know what works
than you do and so you have to be
willing to give up some creative control
to somebody who really knows their
audience to let that campaign win and so
if you focusing more in influencers and
gives them creative control to do what
they want to do to help pump your
product or service number six is content
is going to grow the amount of content
is just going to explode it earlier how
many times you going to conferences now
and you see people holding up
cell phones recording how many people
are recording parts of their daily life
and snapping pictures it's growing like
crazy the supply is out of control and
it's only going to continue to explode
in 2017 and so you need to find a way to
stand out anytime there's a ton of
quantity then it's the quality that will
stand up you have to find your angle you
got to find your niche you got to find
the thing that you do that's different
and so the way for entrepreneurs to
stand out is one you need to create
content right like once a week is going
to become not enough once a week right
now is kind of good once a week is not
going to be enough you're going to have
to move the daily content you need to
find something every day to talk about
in your business and so some ideas you
can share the stories of the people
working with you or the stories of your
customers stories of why you started
this business and what gets you all
excited you can share your expertise it
could be your thoughts on the industry
where it's going it could be questions
that people come in and ask you it could
be from your audience and saying hey can
you make a video about this it could be
what your customers are coming in and
asking you every day in your company
turn those into video or written content
for your channels to start to stand out
it could also be the sawdust of your
company right sawdust used to be seen as
a byproduct that you would throw away
right this is garbage
nobody would ever use it and then
companies realized hey you could turn
sawdust into products right so think
about the stuff that you do day to day
in your business that you never record
that you never share that you never put
out and make the public you could that
behind the scenes authentic stuff is is
where entrepreneurs can win because the
brand's never want to do that the brands
are always so concerned about how it
looks and how people are going to judge
them
is going to pass through legal is going
to pass to all of our PR teams right and
then nothing ends up getting produced
excepting overly produced stuff that
people don't resonate with your change
as an entrepreneur show me behind the
scenes show me how you make your pizza
show me what you're doing to create that
website and your grinding out the code
show me your day-to-day life show me
that behind the scenes stuff make it
authentic make it daily so you can do a
vlog you can you can do a Q&A you can do
storytelling has to be regular
consistent daily content that's quality
if you want to start standing out and
number seven is that the data nerds are
going to rain it's really important to
have both the passion and excitement in
in fire that the entrepreneur founder
can bring but you have to look at the
analytics as well the people who are so
focused on SEO and driving website
traffic and conversion optimization you
know all of that data geek stuff you're
going to have to bring to your social
channels as well understanding how to
hack the YouTube algorithm understanding
how to place Facebook Ads and have a
generate a return on investment whether
that's you if that's you and you love
the science we love the data and you
love diving in and figuring out what
works best and hacking it making it
better and going to conferences and
researching and watching videos and
paying attention to get better
constantly because once you figure out
how to hack YouTube it's going to change
in Fremont you got to stay on top of it
it's a constant battle to stay on top of
the algorithm just like it was in SEO
and so you need to either be that person
or you need that person on your team and
say you know what I don't care about
that stuff I want to focus on creating
the content and being the CEO and being
the leader you need to bring that person
up for it who has the passion loves
keeping up with it or you're going to
you're going to lose to the
entrepreneurs the ones you're going to
win are the ones who get it or bring
somebody on to help them with it you
need to understand the analytics and if
you're if you're that data nerd if you
love staying on top of things and
tweaking and hacking that's going to be
a massive opportunity to you this year
I'm going home so that's what I got
those are my seven ways you can dominate
social media in 2017 I love to know what
do you think what was your favorite one
when are you going to apply immediately
into your
business what did you learn the most
from did I miss something is there an 8
9 10 and you want to add to the list
leave it down in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Jay Wong from
the inner changemaker comm Jay safety so
much for picking up 10 copies on my book
and making that awesome YouTube video
review of it as well I really really
really appreciate it
so evan is coming out of a new book
called the one word or your one word and
it's the idea of that if we pick one
word that is what our whole branding is
about it's what our whole story is going
to be about so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon